if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to 200 off and two
free pillows at
helixsleep.com pacman
so today we start with last night's
election results which are i mean i'll
skip to the conclusion they're an
absolute disaster for democrats they
could spell major trouble for the
democrats and for the left to the extent
that the left exists in the united
states through the democratic party
that's an issue we can talk about as
well um there are a range of opinions
about how much of a disaster last
night's results are and that's fine
but it's not good it's not good the big
race the major race that so many were
looking at was the virginia
gubernatorial uh race
where the democratic governor ralph
northam who won by nine in 2017 in
virginia
was term limited out two contenders were
vying to replace ralph northam it was
democrat terry mcauliffe and republican
glenn younkin now the polls were very
tight over the last three weeks i
continued saying it's basically even
could be plus one or two in either
direction terry mcauliffe a completely
milk-toast democrat not particularly
inspiring in any way
not particularly distressing in any way
other than sort of like distressing in
the sense of is this guy really going to
inspire people to turn out and vote
glenn younkin on the other hand a truly
disgusting radical republican
playing up cultural issues as expected
and as republicans have been doing over
the last many years and younkin won
young can won now interestingly you know
let's put aside for a second
no republicans are claiming fraud that
i'm aware of in any of these races from
yesterday even though you had some
republicans saying it looks like
democrats are stealing votes in virginia
and if mcauliffe wins we'll probably say
there was fraud and now they're all
silent
i mean we can't even deal with that
today because it's so absurd but as the
results went as the results came in
early in the in the night last night um
glenn younkin got up to even a 10 10 and
a half point lead i think at one point
as the more left-leaning counties with
large populations were counted the lead
tightened and tightened but it ended up
being a roughly two-point win in
virginia for the republican glenn
younkin now the scary part
the question we were talking about
yesterday including on our live stream
with many of our viewers from virginia
and it's been written about extensively
in the first few hours of today by all
of the typical political voices
is the virginia gubernatorial election
at bellwether for 2022.
some say yes definitely this spells
disaster for democrats in 2022. others
say
no
some say well maybe somewhat but not
totally
what there is no way to deny
is that bellwether aside for 2022
when the last race for virginia governor
was won by nine by a democrat and now
it's won by two by a republican that's
an 11 point swing in one cycle
that's not good for democrats in
virginia period now in a moment we'll
look at the historical
it's not uncommon
that in virginia the governor's race
goes the opposite way that the white
house went in the previous election
that's not uncommon but it still doesn't
bode well for 2022 even if you can see
that it's a historical pattern so we're
going to talk about that virginia was a
state that we were hoping
was leaning more and more left and
republicans want it republicans want it
and they want it with a really simple
tactic and this is important to
understand
democrats are not very good at messaging
it's almost cliche to say it we've done
so many interviews about it we've talked
to thomas frank about it we've talked to
george lakoff we've talked about it in
so many different ways democrats are not
very good at messaging in particular
republicans know the messaging that will
get people to vote and that will get
people to vote for them
it doesn't matter if it's based in fact
it doesn't matter if it's totally wrong
they understand republicans that if they
get their base angry enough
and scared enough
it will motivate their voters to go to
the polls there is just no way and i
hate that i mean this is not even a
political thing this is almost
psychology sociology
there is no way that democrats can get
the same amount of motivation and energy
to get their base to turn out by
pitching green energy
equal uh equality of opportunity
and all these things that actually
matter
compared to how republicans do it with
fear uh and with um uh anger
and republicans did it in virginia with
talk of
fixing education and getting rid of
critical race theory the very same
republicans think about the absurdity
from a value standpoint the same
republicans who claim that as a value
they don't want government doing too
much they want to limit the areas that
government is even involved they got
people angry and afraid enough to go out
and vote by saying we're going to get in
there and tell schools what to teach
that was a big part of glenn younkin's
campaign and the people around yunkan
interviews with voters republican voters
in virginia showed they were voting
yunkan many of them
because they wanted him to deal with
education and critical race theory it's
absurd
it's absurd and it's counter to their
stated values but it worked and they won
the race then we had the gubernatorial
race in new jersey
now it was believed to be a very safe
seat for the incumbent democratic
governor phil murphy in the blue state
of new jersey where joe biden defeated
donald trump easily in 2022 by 16. biden
beat trump by 16 in jersey in 2020 and
phil murphy did jump out to a big lead
up front
but then as the night went on and we
watched the results come in the
republican challenger gained and gained
and eventually took a two-point lead
now as more votes came in overnight as
of i just looked at it and hopefully
this is not outdated by the time you
listen to today's show but as of just 15
minutes ago the race has not been called
and with 92 reporting phil murphy is
back in the lead but by 0.06 percent
that's not 0.6 percent
it's
0.06 percent about 1300 votes 8
of the ballots still to be counted now
if democrats lose the new jersey
governorship
it's a disaster
even if murphy wins but by less than not
even less than a point less than a tenth
of a point is what the margin is right
now to massive swing in 2017 phil murphy
won by 15 points in new jersey then
biden won easily in 2020 and now phil
murphy's trying to eke out a win by a
tenth of a point as of 15 minutes ago so
no matter who wins republicans closed a
massive gap in a very very blue state
that also doesn't bode well if you were
of the mindset well virginia doesn't
tell us much by itself well it's not by
itself look at virginia and new jersey
and then what else we're going to talk
about more of the results on the bonus
show today
some of the results very much expected
uh democrat eric adams won new york city
mayor a left-leaning candidate michelle
wu one boston mayor and then you know
not surprisingly
self-described socialist india walton
did not win the buffalo mayorship uh
lost by a lot by 17 points to a write-in
candidate i know that many progressives
were very interested in that race uh it
is not super shocking to me
that a self-described socialist
did not get elected mayor of buffalo new
york joe biden won buffalo easily
um but democratic voters are not
necessarily socialist voters and that's
not shocking there and we'll look at
some of the other results on the bonus
show today now i do think it's important
to restate
that in a lot of ways this was a turnout
victory for republicans there were
anecdotally republicans saying my
democratic friends are voting for
republicans this time around in jersey
in virginia in some other races and
anecdotally there are always examples of
everything some republicans who vote
democrat democrats who vote republican
etc but really it was using fear and
anger to get turnout for example terry
mcauliffe actually outperformed joe
biden among some groups
sahil kapoor from nbc news pointed this
out in a tweet and said you know among
white women college graduates
biden got 58 percent of that group in
2020
whereas terry mcauliffe got 62 percent
of that group in 2020 mcauliffe built
the lead
that joe biden had among white women
with college degrees
but it just wasn't enough because other
groups did not turn out in the numbers
that terry mcauliffe needed so
non-college educated white women
voted for yunkan by an even bigger
margin
than they voted for donald trump so what
we had was an exaggeration of the 2020
results with the turnout favoring
republicans now does that mean 2022
looks less bad not really
this could point to a very bad 2022
because midterms are often turnout
elections so democrats need to number
one do some stuff now but what i mean
that sounds silly
they need to get some things done that
they can point to and say hey look at
these things that we actually did you've
you've got to do some things and we're
going to talk about spending an
infrastructure bill a little bit later
but saying that terry mcauliffe simply
ran a bad campaign is myopic new jersey
shouldn't be this close
pennsylvania supreme court won by
republicans if democrats don't want to
accept this as a wake-up call publicly
to save face okay i mean you know
there's debate do you ever really admit
that it was a disaster for you maybe you
don't
but privately democrats had better see
this as a wake-up call and it's almost
more difficult without trump on the
ballot as i've said before it's harder
to say
um even though we haven't done much vote
for us anyway when trump's not there
when it's trump
uh when it's overtly a referendum on
trump the we aren't trump message makes
more sense because trump is such a train
wreck even if you don't have that much
that you've done to point to
you're not trump you're not crazy in
that way
when there's no trump it's well we're
better than these other republicans who
also aren't trump it's weak in terms of
messaging it's weak in terms of framing
and there's a very good article in the
atlantic this morning by elaine godfrey
and russell berman called if democrats
can lose virginia they can lose almost
anywhere which points out that yunkan
neither repudiated nor embraced trump he
really didn't do either he he actually
kind of played koi with trump and we
talked about this all along
and republicans ended up winning that
race now let me now after everything
i've said about how disastrous this
could be let me just present to you the
least disastrous interpretation just so
you know that there is one and it would
be the following
it's really common
that in virginia the governorship goes
to the opposition party when there's a
new president so when carter won in the
next election virginia
gubernatorial went to republicans when
reagan won it then went to democrats
when bush senior won it then went to
democrats when clinton won it switched
to republicans
when george w bush won it switched to
democrats when obama won switched to
republicans and now uh and same with
trump switched to democrats and now we
have biden wins and it switches to
republicans so if you want to point to
that and say that's how virginia works
it's not really a big concern you can
find a justification
in the history to make that claim but
with the new jersey numbers
not looking good
um and with some of these other things
not looking good
i certainly wouldn't be taking that
chance and it's a completely plausible
scenario can't yet say likely a lot of
things need to happen we're we've got a
year until the 2020 midterms which i
think are really going to get going in
late february early march
it could be an absolute bloodbath for
democrats in 2022
if biden then does not run for
re-election which is plausible
um and then you've got you know like a
not super popular kamala harris as the
nominee
there could be a scenario and i always
want to balance being realistic
but not being alarmist but not
downplaying things
we could have a scenario where 2022 is a
disaster for democrats
2024 is a disaster for democrats and you
end up with democrats trying to take
control back of something in 2026
after republicans have gotten
a lot of opportunity to do some serious
damage to this country damage that will
take you know
to 2030 to start undoing i mean it's a
it's a grim and dark potential path and
that's why it's important to see every
single one of these elections in context
so let me know your thoughts let me know
your interpretation we're going to have
more on some of the minor races
on today's bonus show which you can get
access to by becoming a member at
joinedpakman.com and you can find me on
twitter at deepakman and let me know
your interpretation your analysis of
yesterday's election results
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video all right welcome back
everybody remember we do depend on your
support to run our program to fund all
of the things we do pay salaries pay for
equipment pay for connectivity pay for
benefits for employees which i uh
always want to be a good employer and
providing you can grab a membership at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code felony21 to get a discount uh it's
a big discount it's a very big discount
and you'll get access to the daily bonus
show as a member you can sign up at
joinpacman.com so for this week's covid
update we usually do this tuesday or
wednesday i i actually do not have news
for you that daily cases have continued
down in the united states for weeks and
weeks and weeks really since the start
of september i've been telling you
weekly hey guys good news us cases are
declining all the way down last week to
cases being down 59
from the peak during the delta wave but
sadly this week over the last week cases
are still down
relative to that delta peak but no more
than they were last week they basically
flattened we're down 59 percent from the
delta peak to be exact average daily
cases in the u.s are now down
59.99 so like basically 60
not a big change from last week's number
of 59 so for whatever reason and we'll
talk about maybe why
cases have leveled off a bit in the
united states now 60 000
if we're declining
60 000 is you know better than 100 000
better than 160 000 where we were at the
peak of the delta wave
as an endemic flat level if cases are
going to steady you know steady at 60
000 that's not going to cut it for
getting back to what we would call
normal it's just way too high a level
the good news is that deaths have
continued down over the last week maybe
not surprisingly because deaths tend to
lag cases on about a three to four week
delay deaths in the u.s now down about
45 percent from their delta peak which
was close to 2000 now we're seeing about
a thousand fifty eleven hundred coveted
deaths per day in the united states uh
about a third of where we were at the
very worst peak in january of 2021
but way way too high to be anywhere near
what we would call a normal situation
remember that in a typical flu season
u.s coveted deaths i'm sorry u.s flu
deaths average about a hundred a day
over the course of the year
so we are still seeing
10 to 11 times
the daily deaths from covid
than from flu in a typical season
now what's happening around the world
last week we actually saw cases tick up
globally a little bit and we wondered is
it a trend or is it a blip sadly
globally cases have again ticked up just
a little bit not by much basically
steady
last week we were seeing about 420
000 cases of covid per day
we're now seeing about 425
000 cases of covet per day not a big
change but not a good number we've also
seen global deaths kind of level out
slightly tick up not a major change
right now about 7 000 people every day
around the world are dying of covet the
big news in the u.s over the last few
days
is that a cdc panel has unanimously
recommended that the pfizer covet
vaccine be approved for kids ages 5 to
11 that's a major step in starting to
vaccinate kids 5 to 11 that would be a
major step forward in better protecting
people there is the belief that maybe as
soon as this friday the day after
tomorrow five to 11 year olds could
start to get vaccinated we don't yet
know
how many parents plan to get their five
to 11 year olds vaccinated
that's a question it's an empirical
question to which we don't yet have an
answer uh we do know that is going to be
a different dosage the dosage for five
to 11 year olds is going to be about a
third of what it would be for adults and
importantly you you may have read you
may not the way that these uh vibe doses
are distributed
um for adults and 12 plus year olds is
in vials that contain
multiple vaccines at one point it was
five with sort of a little extra
um
there was approval for a 10 dose vial
and you fill the syringe with the
appropriate amount
from what is being said so far in order
to avoid any confusion
not only is the dose one-third for five
to eleven-year-olds but the vials will
be different just so there's no
confusion whatsoever about from this is
the adult vial
and you take x amount you will have a
different sized vial differently labeled
when it's for the 5 to 11 year old so
not only do you put a different amount
in the syringe but it will be coming out
of a different vial all met to reduce
confusion so that's going on
the other news that a few of you sent me
which i don't think there's really any
reason to panic right now it doesn't
sound good the headline is that there's
a potentially faster spreading delta
variant a y
4.2 which has now been spotted in eight
states before people flip out
um it is believed that ay 4.2 spreads
faster than the main delta variant but
there is no evidence at this time that
it causes more severe illness
vaccines remain effective against the ay
4.2 variant and in addition to that
um it is not there is no evidence at
this time that it is going to become a
dominant variant anyway it's a
sublineage it's staying as a very small
fraction of circulating cases and it's
been around for weeks but it is being
studied it's sort of a descendant of the
delta variant um i may get my third dose
this weekend uh netherlands recently
announced everyone will be able to get
third doses including people under 60. i
spoke to my doctor about it my doctor
said right now it's not something where
i'm saying to you sir that's how my
doctor talks to me he says sir he's not
saying sir go and get the third dose for
sure
but if you get it it's fine there's no
downside uh i was vaccinated with my
second dose at the end of february which
which it's been what that's almost nine
months at this point since my second
dose so i'm looking very strongly at
getting my third dose this weekend let's
put it that way that's the latest
uncovered
we'll see what happens between now and
next week
we have some potentially good news about
the infrastructure and spending bill duo
and the news is that it appears
kirsten cinema's office is saying
and senate majority leader chuck schumer
seems to be confirming that prescription
drug price controls may be back in the
bill now on monday we played video
and audio i mean it'd be weird to just
play video with no audio we played audio
and video of bernie being interviewed
over the weekend bernie sanders senator
from vermont saying
i'm still working on the prescription
drug price stuff
and my hope is that we're going to be
able to get it in the bill so let's look
at what we learned in the last 24 hours
kirsten cinema putting out a statement
cinema office statement on historic
medicare drug negotiation agreement
a quote from john la bombard kirsten
cinemas communications director after
senator cinema reached earlier agreement
with president biden to include historic
medicare drug negotiation in the
reconciliation package policies that
were omitted from the initial framework
at the request of members of the house
speaker pelosi reached out to senator
cinema this past weekend to continue
negotiations the senator welcomes a new
agreement on a historic transformative
medicare drug negotiation plan that will
reduce out-of-pocket costs for seniors
ensuring drug prices cannot rise faster
than inflation save taxpayer dollars and
protect innovation to ensure arizonans
and americans continue to have access to
life-saving medications and new cures
and therapeutics
we also thank representatives peters and
schroeder for their work on this
historic agreement so there were
questions like what the hell is going on
here we then heard from senate majority
leader chuck schumer agreeing they are
doing this let's go to some clips of
chuck schumer
i'm pleased to announce that an
agreement has been reached
to lower prescription drug prices for
seniors and families in the build back
better legislation
fixing prescription drug pricing has
consistently been a top issue for
americans year after year
including the vast majority of both
democrats and republicans continuing uh
was
chuck schumer to say
more specifics about what it is that's
been negotiated in the direction things
may be going here
by empowering medicare to directly
negotiate prices in part b and part d
this deal will directly reduce
out-of-pocket drug spending for millions
of patients every time they visit the
pharmacy or doctor
it will cap out-of-pocket spending at 2
000 per year
ending the days where a life-changing
diagnosis could mean thousands upon
thousands of dollars in new expenses
okay so some specifics there
and then um just a few more details here
from senate minority senate majority
leader chuck schumer and senator um
cinema right
has told me she supports this agreement
so i think we're there
it's not everything we all wanted
many of us would have wanted to go much
further yeah but it's a big step in
helping the american people deal with
the price of drugs right
so uh i mean listen should we be happy
that something related to controlling
prescription drug prices is presumably
going to be in the bill
yes yeah i mean we could be happy about
that that's okay that's reasonable um
should we be furious that this was even
a debate
and that it's one of the many things in
addition to
paid leave
more environmental regulated all the
different things we talked about
medicare expansion that was pulled from
these bills
yes it's dystopian and disturbing that
we're even having these negotiations
today no question about that um should
progressives still
kill the bill as i suggested last week
maybe they they should do
listen you guys know that i'm the
ultimate pragmatist
in the past i've taken heat for saying
don't kill a bill because it contains
some good stuff
last week i said
the bills have now been so gutted
maybe it is time to kill the bill
because what we mostly have are sort of
like infrastructure slush funds for
corporations etc and i said maybe it is
and then a bunch of people became
furious for me saying yeah real
pragmatic pacman killing a bill that
actually has stuff in it that makes
sense um
my position at this point is
if this can be passed soon in the next
few weeks so that it's truly done before
uh the house and senate recess for the
end of the year
and it does have some climate-related
elements in it
and it does have some worthwhile
infrastructure spending and it now has
some although not nearly what we would
like to see um prescription drug price
controls
i i say pass it
but i think
whether the individual bill
is killed
or passes as it would likely pass given
what we understand about it now
it's not going to be enough to save
democrats in 2022. so on balance would i
rather some things be passed than not
yes yes i would
um is it
potentially even going to be like a
pyrrhic victory for democrats to some
degree yeah it may be it's not going i
mean listen we looked at what happened
yesterday with the results
passing a milk toast bill
is not going to be nearly enough to vote
to motivate democratic voters in a year
to vote in the november of 22 midterms
compared with the effectiveness that we
know
the fomenting of anger and the fomenting
of fear on cultural issues by
republicans will have on their
electorate so pass the bill sure you
know i'm not going out there and saying
kill it it's just more an exercise in
frustration as to how long this has been
going on and how much weaker and weaker
and weaker the bill is now it's gotten
slightly less weak with the addition of
the prescription drug controls um
okay pass it fine but if anybody thinks
this is what's going to save democrats
in 2022 oh no no no no and yesterday's
election results across the country
should be a reminder of that uh we're
going to take a quick break we'll have
more coverage of this on the david
pakman show instagram which you can find
at david pakman show you can find me on
instagram at david.pakman after the
break we'll be talking about a new poll
from the prri public
religion research institute i believe it
is
um telling us that 30 of republicans now
openly support using violence to achieve
their political goals
my question is how many support it but
don't openly say it so we'll talk about
that after the break and much much more
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
so we know intuitively and we know
because of what happened on january 6th
that there are some republicans some
portion of the republican electorate
that is willing to turn to violence that
sees violence as legitimate or at least
justified
in order to achieve
their
political goals there's a new study from
the public uh public research public
public religion research institute
that looks very specifically at who are
the americans that are willing to turn
to violence to achieve their political
objectives and we're going to look at
that right now salon summarizes this
as an alarming finding but no surprise
many republicans now ready to support
violence new prri poll finds direct
links between trump's big lie far-right
media and support for potential violence
new public opinion research
the 12th annual american value survey
from the public religion research
institute has alarming findings close to
a third of republicans in the survey 30
percent agree with the statement true
american patriots
may have to resort to violence in order
to save our country that's more than the
combined total of democrats and
independents who say the same thing at
11 and 17 respectively let's look at the
numbers we're going to look at some
other elements of this study because
it's really well done really interesting
the question was
how do you agree with the statement
true american patriots might have to
resort to violence
in order to save our country per party
affiliation and selected attitudes so
first of all
almost one-fifth of americans do believe
that true american patriots might have
to resort to violence to save uh their
country all right 18 of americans say
yes
um
the largest group
by party identification is republicans
30 percent of republicans believe
violence may be justified to save the
country
what's very interesting
is that if you look at their media
consumption
the republicans who trust mainstream
news
only 22 percent believe they may need to
turn to violence of the republicans who
most trust fox news
the number goes up to 32 percent believe
they may need to turn to violence and if
fox news is too
liberal
for
republicans and they only trust
far-right news presumably stuff like
newsmax oan and conspiracy stuff
then
a full 40 percent of them
40 believe that violence may be
justified which is stunning now um 17 of
independents and about 1 out of 10
democrats also believe the same and in
terms of specific beliefs if you believe
that the 2020 election was stolen from
donald trump there's a four out of 10
chance that you also believe violence
may be necessary or appropriate
um
if you believe god has granted america a
special role in human history 27 chance
okay so those are very very disturbing
numbers for one very specific reason
there are 30 percent of republicans
willing to admit in a poll
that they would be supportive of
violence how many republicans would be
supportive of violence but aren't
willing to admit it in a poll it's some
number for sure and i don't know exactly
um what what that number would be but
that's also a significant concern now
there's lots of things to look at in
this study
um just a couple of others in terms of
attitudes and i encourage you to check
we're linking to this check out the
entire study
one interesting question that was
studied is
has the us always been a force for good
in the world
and has there never been a time you were
not proud to be an american so overall
74 percent of americans believe america
has always been a force for good in the
world
and 58 percent of americans say there
was never a time i was not proud to be
an american not surprisingly republicans
are far more likely to believe that than
democrats
but it's not like democrats are slouches
the the portrayal the stereotype so to
speak
is democrats don't really like the us
democrats have a very anti-american
attitude if you look at these questions
it's not that low i mean sick two-thirds
of democrats still believe america has
always been a force for good in the
world
uh by the stereotypes of patriotism it's
not very unpatriotic
um okay among other groups
white evangelicals and white
non-evangelical protestants seem to be
the most
stereotypically pro-american now i say
stereotypically because for me being
pro-american means very different things
than it means to these groups but by
these definitions followed by white
catholics and then hispanic catholics
maybe not surprisingly the religiously
unaffiliated are those least likely to
hold these
stereotypically patriotic views
um about the united states of america um
one other thing we we kind of talk about
this idea of idealizing the 1950s that
is prevalent among the american right
and when they talk about conserving
and getting back to when america was
great it's often the the 1950s that they
have in mind one of the questions that
this really is a great study you should
you should really page through it
um people were asked do you think life
has mostly changed for the better since
the 1950s
among democrats
close to two-thirds believe life is
better now than it was in the 1950s
among independents about half believe
life is better now than it was in the
1950s
only 29 of republicans believe that life
is now better than it was in the 1950s
and that's very telling when we think
about
conservatism what do they want to
conserve what do they want to go back to
and and it seems as though it's often
this kind of 1950s idea it's not wrong
it's not wrong uh not wrong to believe
that
um
last
thing i want to look at
what traits do you associate with being
truly american and a really excellent
question
where you see
agreement where between all americans
republicans and democrats there's not
much of a difference are
believing in individual freedoms like
freedom of speech
republicans and democrats basically
united that is something that is truly
american
believing every citizen should be able
to vote in elections
almost exact numbers between democrats
and republicans accepting people of
diverse racial and religious backgrounds
you start to see a little bit of a split
republicans
slightly less than democrats believe
that
um but where you really start to see
differences is
on
questions like being able to speak
english is being able to speak english a
sign of being truly american
93 percent of republicans say yes
whereas only 68 of democrats say yes
believing that capitalism is the best
economic system you see a 27-point gap
between republicans and democrats on
whether that is a sign of being really
american
believing in god
there is a 33 point gap almost 80
percent of republicans believe that to
be truly american you must believe in
god
less than half of democrats believe that
um and then uh an interesting one being
of western european heritage a sort of
white supremacist belief
as being truly american
one-fifth of republicans believe that
but almost one-fifth of democrats
believe that as well okay
check out the study we're linking to it
and um recall of course that when it
comes to this openness to violence to
solve political problems
um recall that
republicans claim to be about law and
order until they are not
they claimed to be about supporting the
police until january 6th when suddenly
they didn't support the police they
claimed to be about business freedom
until some businesses started saying hey
we want our employees to be vaccinated
against cobit then they weren't about
business freedom anymore i could spend
the whole show giving you examples but
the point here is they regularly
fantasize about things that they claim
they don't want to see they claim they
want to prevent the collapse of society
and yet increasingly they're willing to
cause it in order to achieve what they
believe will be successful political
outcomes i continue to see january 6th
as a sort of trial for more violence in
the future there have barely been
consequences for the rioters so far
starting to see some no consequences for
the insiders including members of
congress trump staffers trump himself
and so it shouldn't come as a shock to
us that the number of republicans
willing or who believe violence may be
appropriate to achieve political gain uh
is as high as it actually is so send me
your thoughts on that here's an
interesting story
there is a group of uh fed up
republicans in texas
that are buying
billboards that say trump lost these are
republicans who don't like the big lie
republicans apparently former president
donald trump has been pushing for audits
even in states where he won
but some anti-trump republicans are
putting their foot down in texas
my san antonio reports that three
billboards have sprung up in san antonio
that bluntly declared trump lost while
at the same time demanding no more
audits of the 2020 election in their
state remember that
republican governor greg abbott
announced we're going to audit four
counties or something like that remember
trump won texas but lost overall
according to my san antonio the
billboards are being sponsored by an
organization called republicans for
voting rights spending a quarter of a
million dollars to pay for billboards in
texas georgia florida pennsylvania
michigan virginia wisconsin and arizona
a trump-backed audit in arizona
conducted over the summer failed to
prove that trump won the state and in
fact gave joe biden more votes despite
this trump continues to push for more
audits imma i don't want to spend a lot
of time on this story
but imagine needing huge signs to tell
you something as obvious as trump lost
but they do and republicans in a lot of
these states including texas because
there's a lot of republicans some of
these other states because people
republicans in those states have become
convinced that trump actually won those
states even though he didn't
lots of the republicans i think it's
important to mention disavow this one
fairy tale there are a lot there are
tens of millions i would estimate of
republicans who disavow the fairy tale
that trump actually won
but they fully believe other republican
fairy tales they believe trickle down
economic works uh they believe the
national debt should be thought of just
like household debt uh and so while you
know you give credit where credit is due
there are some republicans like liz
cheney who
don't believe the fairy tale that trump
won they believe many other fairy tales
that are basically just as destructive
to the united states also remember that
lots of republicans don't literally
believe trump won they see saying that
trump won as a sort of loyalty test a
loyalty oath in a war that they see
themselves as fighting so
for some of these republicans that might
see these billboards telling them trump
lost
doesn't change their view on the facts
it's not even an empirical argument for
them
it just makes them see you as the enemy
and to these republicans who continue to
say trump won republicans willing to
admit that trump didn't win are actually
the enemy
um so you know but republicans can spend
money doing whatever they want in this
case it's i guess trying to convince
other republicans trump didn't really
win many of those republicans sort of
already know that there are some
republicans who believe literally trump
won but for many of them it's just this
is what i say
to demonstrate that i'm on the team that
i'm doing the right things and that i'm
i'm playing the role i'm supposed to
play uh send me your thoughts we're
gonna take a quick break and we'll be
back with much more right after this
you value what we do at the david pakman
show remember to support us on patreon
go to patreon.com davidpakmanshow where
you can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show okay let's get to a few other
stories um there's been a lot of talk
from donald trump about his record in
endorsing people
and it'll be interesting to see
with glenn yunken
winning in virginia how much credit
donald trump takes trump taking a a
moment during his interview with janine
pirro over the weekend to say i endorsed
yunkan and i endorsed him strongly
i assure you if junkin had lost trump
would have said well i endorsed him but
he didn't really embrace me
youngen did win and presumably trump is
going to take credit there trump's
record is actually not that great on
endorsements but not only from a numbers
standpoint trump's also endorsed some
really horrible people
one such person appears to be senate
candidate sean parnell who now is
accused by his wife of strangling her
and beating their children there's a
report in rolling stone about this which
says wife of trump-backed senate
candidate sean parnell
claims he strangled her
beat their children
estranged wife lori snell also alleged
the republican candidate told her to go
get an abortion
lori snell the estranged wife of
pennsylvania senate candidate sean
parnell
testified during a court hearing on
monday alleging that her husband
strangled her
parnell denies this also made other
claims her testimony which alleged both
verbal and physical abuse took place
during a hearing in butler pennsylvania
in a child custody proceeding over their
three children in their divorce case she
had previously sought temporary
protective orders against parnell in
2017 and 2018 although both were later
expunged former president donald trump
endorsed sean parnell in september for
his run in the republican primary
parnell is vying for pennsylvania's open
senate seat in 2022 in what's shaping up
to be one of the most hotly contested
senate races next year that is a big
race um
she said he tried to choke me out on a
couch and i literally had to bite him he
was strangling me in another incident
she claimed parnell slapped one of the
children so hard it left visible
fingerprint shaped welts she also
testified he was verbally abusive in
another incident she alleged he forced
her out of her vehicle and told her to
go get an abortion now that's
politically relevant because on
parnell's campaign website he states i
am pro-life
will always vote to protect the unborn
if true and these are allegations if
true it would be another instance of
hypocrisy of a gap between stated values
and how they actually live in real life
in a statement issued by the campaign
parnell denied the allegations and said
he would present the truth to the court
next week let me emphatically state i
have never raised a hand in anger
towards my wife or any of our three
children what happened today in court
was not justice nor did it have any
basis in fact or truth now a lot of
people will write to me they'll say
david how you know you can't say these
things happen these are allegations
which have been refuted and that's
absolutely and completely fine
i'm more interested
in the reality the undeniable reality
that these types of allegations
even when proven credible
no longer torpedo your chances at least
if you're a republican we've actually
seen you could argue to a fault over the
last decade the al franken incident is
arguably one of these
situations where democrats hold their
own to very different standards than
republicans um and there was a time when
something like this would kill your shot
at winning and times have really changed
you could argue that a key moment in
this trajectory was when the access
hollywood tape came out with donald
trump talking about when you're famous
they just let you do it you just grab
them by the you-know-what
nothing happened nothing happened there
was a time when that could have ended a
campaign today it won't even necessarily
get donald trump to revoke his
endorsement of you for now donald trump
has not revoked his endorsement of sean
parnell i wouldn't expect him to for the
time being hell
sean parnell could end up being the
republican presidential candidate this
wouldn't even necessarily disqualify him
uh from that so it is very much uh the
case that the pennsylvania senate race
is going to be a big big deal
in um 2022 the 2022 elections in the
united states are going to be
wide-ranging and important there are
actually a number of seats uh
pennsylvania
ohio
um
maybe maybe missouri
um north carolina
and alabama where there are retiring
republican senators retiring republican
senators doesn't mean a democrat can win
but it at least will not be a democrat
going up against an incumbent and those
are real opportunities and as we've
talked before about the joe manchin
problem i continue to say
the way to fix the senate
is by flipping some red states blue
it's not by primary mansion and then
having whoever defeats mansion if
anybody
lose to a republican in the general in
west virginia it's just it's literally
not a solution in that it actually gives
republicans an additional seat so we're
going to keep an eye on the sean parnell
allegations another beauty of an
endorsement from donald trump these are
just allegations for the time being just
important to mention that
um there is a reason why
in this story's youtube clip
i'm using the word accidentally in
quotes
because
when it comes to accidentally firing a
gun
we really shouldn't be using the word
accidental we should be using the word
negligent we should be using the word
reckless
the headline as it's being reported by
wlox and others is that a woman had a
gun in her purse during a basketball
game
okay
and she accidentally fired the gun
i don't think accidentally is really the
right word that we should be using here
but the story is a woman has been given
a 500 dollar bond
after firing a gun at a basketball game
in madison
madison mississippi that is
according to police the incident
happened inside the gym at rosa scott
school monday night
during the game kashan alexis mcrunnels
reached into her purse to grab her phone
but accidentally fired her gun nobody
was hurt but the game was suspended
while investigators escorted mcrunnels
to a secure office inside the school
mcrunnels did have an enhanced concealed
carry permit or permit as some folks
like to say which allowed her to have
the firearm at the event however she was
charged with discharging a firearm
within the city limits of madison in
violation of the city of madison
ordinance mcrunnels was given a 500 bond
and a court date to appear before
madison municipal court
accidentally means negligent discharge
we have to stop normalizing
these incidents by calling them
accidents and that's why i'm calling
this quote
accidentally
it's the wrong word
it was a negligent discharge
that was related to the reckless
handling of a firearm
imagine now it didn't happen here but it
happens all the time
imagine
ending someone's life
with such a dumb mistake it's happened
we've covered the stories
even
i mean this is now
kind of a whole other topic in a sense
because
some people pointing out this was a
legal concealed
carry individual
licensed
even the classes that are run in many
states are kind of a joke as i've said
before i don't talk about whether i own
guns so i'm just going to couch this
generally
there are many liberals i know that own
guns who have said
the classes really can be passed by
morons
and we know that to be true because of
the number of instances where it's not a
crim someone who criminally obtained a
gun
doesn't have a permit doesn't have a
concealed carry permit whatever people
who are licensed and up-to-date on
everything that they're supposed to do
who behave recklessly and negligently
with firearms and if and until and i'm
like a broken record on this if and
until accidents
are actually treated like the serious
negligence that they are
i don't think we're going to see
anything change the madison cothorn
incident is just a perfect example of
this
where um republican congressman madison
cawthorne tried to board a plane from i
think it was somewhere to charlotte
maybe it was asheville to charlotte or
something like that
and he
tried in the sense that he had
a firearm
in his carry-on he tried to board a
plane to get through tsa security with a
firearm and it was chalked oh it was an
accident he didn't know the gun was in
the bag as if that's an excuse
if you don't know where your firearm is
if you believe the firearm that you're
responsible for
which is a huge responsibility if you
believe that firearm is in one place and
it's actually in a different place
that's reckless that's negligent it's
not an excuse to say i didn't think it
was in my in my bag
that's an indication that we should be
reviewing whether you should even be
allowed to have that gun at all so
we're gonna you know it's an issue we're
gonna continue covering and the extent
to which this is something democrats
should should be running on i've said
before i don't know that it's
pragmatically speaking a good issue to
win elections particularly in places
where it's very purple purple to reddish
but it's an issue that's not going away
anytime soon
here is an interesting voicemail about
vaccination incentives we talk about
carrot versus stick if you want to call
me
you can call 2192davidp
any time of day a few hints for
voicemails number one don't leave me
three five seven twelve voicemails in a
row if you do that they almost certainly
are not going to be played that's one
bit of advice second bit of advice do
not leave voicemails that are the full
three minutes long we have never played
a three minute voicemail on the show
that's the maximum that is allowed on
our voicemail system voicemails tend to
be
between 30 and 90 seconds
and number three get to your point
quickly and this voicemail does all of
these things it's 32 seconds long we can
hear the caller clearly and he gets
right to his point and the question is
why are people getting rewarded for not
getting vaccinated in the sense that the
longer you wait the more likely it is
you'll be offered 100 bucks or free
sports tickets or whatever the case may
be take a listen
david seriously why are people getting
rewarded for not taking the vaccine why
are states giving people who haven't
taken the vaccine money right
i i really don't understand the logic
behind it i guess it's like this
incentive thing
the carrot and stick mentality but it's
really like
why don't i get it i got it a long time
ago i was a participant in this fight to
end this thing why don't i get my
hundred dollars right no listen
this is a good point
which is if you did the right thing
because it was the right thing to do
early you typically got no reward at all
now some states said we're gonna do a
lottery and no matter when you got
vaccinated you can
you can enter to win
million dollars or sometimes less
whatever
uh but there are many cases where the
incentives get a hundred bucks get a
gift card get whatever
they are only open to people getting
vaccinated after a certain date and it
only starts because not enough people
are getting vaccinated so in a sense it
is sort of backwards in that the people
eligible for the rewards are those who
did not get vaccinated when they could
have and morally speaking when they
should have i get it it's a very good
question and it's something i continue
to struggle with at the end of the day i
don't really care
because i just want people getting
vaccinated but there's no doubt that the
caller makes a very good point
we have such a good bonus show for you
today i can't even put it into words
we're going to give you more results
from last night's election some of the
less prominent races we're going to talk
about them on today's bonus show
speaking of firearms which we just did
the white house is introducing a new
plan to reduce gun suicides it's very
common that whenever you want to talk
about gun safety right wingers will
always say the real issue is something
else you talk about mass shootings
they'll say the real issue is handgun
homicides not mass shootings one-off
homicides and then you try to talk about
those and they say well the real issue
is suicides with guns well these are
three different issues mass shootings
single gun homicides and gun suicides
each requires a different approach and
different solutions and the white house
has a new proposal for dealing with gun
suicides going to talk about that on
today's bonus show and then lastly
marjorie taylor green has i guess we
could say quietly accrued 48 000 in
fines for ignoring the mask requirement
of the house of representatives has she
paid it has she paid any of it will she
be forced to pay it we will talk about
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpacman.com and
you will get instant access i will see
you there or sadly if you're not a
member
we'll see you tomorrow but i would love
to have you on the bonus show you can
use the coupon code felony21 it's not
really a felony to use the coupon code
but these discounts are so extreme
that some in the audience imagine it's
got to be illegal this kid this such a
big discount can't be can't be legal
it's completely legal you can use the
coupon code felony21 get the discount
i'll see you on today's bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to dollars off and
two free pillows at helix sleep dot com
slash pacman